what's going on guys this is Rob if you
guys enjoy my content make sure you hit
the subscribe button and make sure you
hit that little bell so you never miss
out on my sexy voice
okay so I've been thinking about this
for the last couple days or so and my
question here is can Aquaman kill the DC
Universe and when I see the DC Universe
I mean like the most prominent heroes
right I mean you could kill like a lot
of different people but the most
prominent heroes so like Superman Shazam
Batman the flash Wonder Woman Green
Lantern any one of the Green Lantern's
will say that Hal Jordan is the only
Green Lantern on earth just to make it
easy but my question is can Aquaman kill
them all all right now Aquaman by
himself
probably not but Aquaman with help can
definitely do it
and here's reason why it would take
Aquaman and then Mara his wife and then
the drift in order to pull it off if
those guys you don't know what the drift
is the drift are like the the Atlantean
black ops team they're like they're
super high-end black ops soldiers
they're designed to kind of go through
and commit certain acts and do things
that are supposed to for the most part
be kept off the radar
but here's the thing in order for
Aquaman to destroy the entirety of the
DC Universe like to kill all the most
prominent superheroes it would take like
surgical precision right like it would
have to be planned out Aquaman couldn't
just get mad one day and it's like blah
or I'm gonna kill everybody you know and
then just attack everyone and then when
there are ways to do it and there are
ways to get around it but still we're
not necessarily gonna go with like the
Dark Knight's metal version of Aquaman
where that I guess really aqua woman
that you know a version of Bruce Wayne
who is a chick that became aqua woman
we're not gonna go with that we're gonna
go more with like like the Aquaman
himself like the main Aquaman Arthur
curry now here's the thing something
would have to happen to set this off
right let's it let's let's say that like
Aquaman overhears all the Justice League
you know like yeah man Aquaman talks to
fish which is true but he doesn't like
hearing it he's just like he's like
Aquaman fans he just doesn't like to
hear the fact that he talks to fish even
though it's true we all know it's true
but for the character of of Arthur this
would take like a planned out thing so
he hears them like saying oh yeah you
know Aquaman talks to fish and he's like
that's the last straw and he freaks out
you know he's like all mighty Neptune
like they're all they're all gonna
perish alright from there he would have
to gather the drift and he would have to
start going through and individually
taking out the various heroes but it
would have to be done in a way to where
nobody else knew what was really going
on like someone like Martian Manhunter
he can be taken out in the blink of an
eye all you have to do is just show fire
just just be like oh here's a simple
lighter Martian Manhunter he's a cool
you know and the fire boy and then he
would run or do whatever he does or
something along those lines but in all
seriousness um taking out taking out
Martian Manhunter taking out Green
Lantern and taking out Wonder Woman
those would be the three hardest if I'm
being honest with you guys first
Superman
that would be super easy it
justtake Aquaman running up on him with
kryptonite like getting his hands on
green kryptonite in subway and there's
all kinds of places you can find at Lex
Corp has it Amanda Waller in the Suicide
Squad have it I mean he could send the
drift in is this black ops team just
have them like invade you know someplace
or even go through and access like the
Justice League Watchtower and like
snatch some green kryptonite and then
literally keep it on his person so that
when he encounters Superman his powers
are basically gone and he kills him with
a trident and that's it for him so
Superman's done and out of the picture
the issue with that is that would have
to be done in a way that's kind of off
the reservation right like he would have
to contact Superman and say hey I need
you to come to Atlanta I need to talk to
you about something because Superman's a
big name and so it would literally have
to be a thing of you know like him
contacting the Justice thing and saying
hey guys Superman's gonna be off for a
little bit he and I need to have a
conversation we're talking about the
relations between like the service world
in the atlantean world or something
along those lines something that seems
innocuous so the Justice League wouldn't
have a reason to question what's going
on because if they start to wonder and
start to question things could go south
now that would lead to Batman beginning
to suspect something because Batman's
always suspicious right like Batman's
but he never trusts anybody he's like
the ultimate cynic trust issues galore
and so Batman sits down and he would say
okay what if there's something going on
here like Aquaman never invites Superman
he never invites anybody from the
Justice League to Atlantis that almost
never happens so what if there's
something going on I better use you know
my prep time and spy because you know
prep time excuses whatever all right at
that point it would that's when you
implement the drift that's when you
would send the drift in and you and you
would have Arthur curry say hey look
here are the weaknesses of the Batcave
assuming he knows them all or he would
say the identity of Batman is Bruce
Wayne and so wait like you he would
probably not kind of like schedule it
right so he would say okay so when Bruce
Wayne is out doing his own thing and
he's doing the whole business thing
that's when Superman gets recalled
that's when the drifter sent out and
they take out Bruce Wayne but is
orchestrating assault on him and so it's
just like okay he's taking out he's
eliminated now by that point assuming
that that happens this surface world
begins to ask questions because they say
okay this is Bruce Wayne who was taken
out in broad daylight by what are
obviously members of the Atlantean
community and that's when like by that
point in time Superman's dealt with and
done like he's gone and out of the
picture so because the surface world
begins to wonder what's going on that
leads to like the flash intervening and
Wonder Woman intervening the Green
Lantern Martian Manhunter they all
basically begin to show up and they
start asking questions inter Mira this
is really when Mira I think like shows
her full force because for someone who
can control water the way she does she's
far more dangerous than people think she
is one thing to bear in mind when it
comes to wonder woman is she could hold
her breath for a very long time so she's
very very capable in that regard she can
just hold her breath until the powers of
Mira die down or whatever the case may
be
or she can just fly out of the water or
something like that so Wonder Woman's
gonna be difficult to catch her there
Green Lantern it's most as much the same
way Green Lantern could create like a
bubble around himself that would
basically shield him and allow him to
breathe inside of it or he could fly
away to or something along those lines
they become dangerous the flash could be
easily dealt with Mira could take him
out in the blink of an eye we know that
from Justice League versus Suicide Squad
when Amanda Waller's answer for subduing
the flash was to encase him in water so
that he couldn't run there was nothing
for him to run on he was in a liquid
surface now that is of course assumes
that you don't run with the frances mana
pool no pun intended
you don't run with a frances mana pool
new 52 flash story where they said he
can basically run on crystallized air
when it's at a high enough altitude and
water vapor freezes and like run on that
and and so on like assuming you don't go
with that something that's just kind of
out of the middle of nowhere I mean I'm
sure flash fans will they'll look for
like any reason to make sure their
character wins but for the most part
flash would just kind of be stuck
because there's nothing for him to make
momentum out of I guess you could start
spinning and maybe that would super heat
the water I'm not entirely sure I mean
that's entirely possible convert it into
steam but from that point like that's
when you literally get into like the
rest of the drift and you get an Aquaman
himself facing off against everybody now
Aquaman's danger really comes in the
form of his Trident I mean he is super
fast in the water you can swim it like I
want to say you can swim is what's
basically 6,800 miles per hour under
water so whatever that equates to in
feet per second at least that was
according to the pre new 52 version but
still you would basically have Aquaman
intervening with a stripe now with him
showing up to his Trident with his
Trident he could in turn do the exact
same thing norm did in throne of
Atlantis
where the fight kind of leads to the
surface uses his tribe he controls of
storms lightning rains down on like
Martian Manhunter and it rains down on
on Hal Jordan the Green Lantern it rains
down on the flash and Wonder Woman now
from there things get pretty simple
right like you you literally thin the
herd like well you're talking about
something like electricity or fire like
you could he could use enough of that to
kill almost all of them Wonder Woman is
highly durable and assuming that the
Green Lantern didn't get his you know
didn't get a shield up fast enough to
protect himself before he was actually
struck by lightning then he would be
down too and so that I would say would
probably leave Wonder Woman left and
Wonder Woman she's I would say the most
dangerous member of the Justice League
because she has no true weakness that's
the thing about Wonder Woman it is not a
kryptonite she doesn't rely on something
like the Green Lantern ringing to give
her powers she's just inherently
powerful and so it's like Superman
without kryptonite and so from there
like it would really come down to like a
battle between the two the fact that you
can't really be caught like she can't
really be encased in water super
strength and speed and durability and
all those kind of least somewhat
durability it would just come down to a
fight like it would just come down to a
fight between Wonder Woman and Aquaman
if I'm a betting man I would give the
fight to Wonder Woman just because she
can do a lot of the things that Aquaman
can't she is she's far faster than he is
she's stronger than he is and she can
fly faster than he can only think you
fly like she can fly anyway there's a
lot of things that she brings to the
table that Aquaman just can't do
I mean honestly she might be able to
grab him and just fly him up into the
middle of nowhere but but at that point
we're also leaving out the drift and
we're also leaving out mirror between
all three groups if we say the drift
Mara and Aquaman Wonder Woman Falls
there's no way she can I don't think she
can stand against all three because
you'd be talking about her facing off
against the Atlantean black ops team
you'd be talking about her facing off
against Mara who controls water and then
you'd be talking about her facing off
against Aquaman with the power of storms
you know because of his Trident and so
on and so forth
she's capable but I don't think she's
that capable I mean we could include
other people like Billy Batson white
like Shazam but you can have the drift
take him out when he's just Billy when
he's just a little kid he's just done in
the blink of an eye I don't really know
a direction that you would go with with
Wonder Woman I would give the fight to
her I would say Wonder Woman could beat
Aquaman but unless she could beat all
three but again the drift are capable
but those seem almost like foot soldiers
maybe like saying the Ninja Turtles
would lose against the foot nobody would
believe that so I don't know I'm curious
I would leave it to you guys I'm curious
do you think that Wonder Woman could
defeat the the Atlantean black ops team
and mera and Aquaman at the same time do
you think she can pull it off I don't
think she could and even then like like
we're not even really giving it a like
we're never giving it like a ton of
thought I mean we could sit down and
like map it all out and we could like
compare powers and all that kind of
stuff because I think Martian Manhunter
may be taken out by lightning or
probably not because he is super super
durable and super strong to me he's more
powerful than Superman if you believe
the Old Grant Morrison JLA Comics so
like Martian Manhunter himself may still
be around and with heat vision and so on
and so forth and all those things but he
could just turn the water to steam and
just like super heat like over heat
Aquaman destroy the drift just shoot
lasers through them so if Martian
Manhunter and Aquaman and Wonder Woman
were left they could easily destroy
Aquaman the drift and mirror they could
destroy them all single-handedly and and
Martian Manhunter could probably do it
by himself just by shape-shifting and
turning into different things and using
its telepathy and so on and so forth I
mean that would be the big kicker is
like being able to orchestrate the
attacks by being able to orchestrate
with Wonder Woman reading his mind and
the two of them acting in a way where
like Aquaman and mirror and the drift
don't know what they're doing then like
at that point they would all fall but I
don't know I mean we're also leaving out
like a bunch of other heroes - we're
leaving out like a bunch of other
characters I don't know I mean it gets
it gets kind of crazy I'd be curious to
see what you guys think I feel like we
should like I should send this to my
writer and have him like flesh the whole
thing out and and literally like tell
the whole story like submit to Ryan I
haven't given him any assignments for a
while senator Ryan haven't flushed the
whole thing out and then come to a
conclusion on what like who would
actually win like like write the whole
story out and then go from it I think
I'm gonna do that I think I wanna have
him research everybody write the whole
story out and then go from there because
I'm just kind of doing this off top my
head but if you are new here to comment
explain make sure you guys hit the sub
button to become part of the Rob core if
you guys enjoy this video make sure you
drop a like and I will catch you all
later peace
[Music]
[Music]